[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez gwyneth paltrow vous
l'avez sans doute vu dans ce film à la
fin des années 90 cooke aus
[Musique]
mais depuis dix ans la crise à délaisser
un peu le cinéma pour se concentrer sur
une autre industrie le bien-être
[Musique]
groupe c le nom de son entreprise
vaudrait aujourd'hui 250 millions de
dollars selon plusieurs médias
américains
alors ça comme si tout simplement avec
une infolettre que vnf pour tout envoyer
ta cuisine avec des recettes des
conseils voyage est maintenant en bourse
est devenu un magazine une balade aux
instits well done toutes sortes de
conseils beauté mode santé et qui vante
autour de produits beauté mode temps le
hic c'est qu'il ya certains s'y produit
qui n'auraient pas les bienfaits sur la
santé que goupe leurs attributs goldman
sachs comme le fameux oeuvre de jade que
les femmes peuvent insérer dans leur
vagin pour équilibrer leur cycle
menstruel et améliorer leur vie sexuelle
ça c'est ce qui était écrit sur le site
de groupe dans ce dossier l'entreprise a
payé 5 45 mille dollars pour publicité
mensongère et ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'on reproche à goop de
désinformer le public il y a plein de
contenus sur le site qui n'est pas
appuyée par la science elle soutient que
les soutiens-gorge cause le cancer
c'est faux a déjà recommandé aux femmes
de se faire piquer le visage par des
abeilles fait une mauvaise idée
groupe voit son rôle différemment
l'entreprise qui est basée à los angeles
dit vouloir présenter diverses
perspectives médicales y compris des
points de vue habituellement négligé par
la médecine conventionnelle et c'est aux
femmes selon groupe de décider ce qui
est mieux pour elle un think tank
on comble le vide dans marché parfois on
décrit une pratique médicale pour
laquelle il n'ya pas eu d'étude clinique
et les gens pensent que les femmes sont
tellement influençable que s'ils ont
publié un article sur l'oeuvre de jade
des millions de femmes vont soudainement
l'utiliser l'oeuvre de jade était en
rupture de stock
juste après son lancement mais la
rhétorique de groupe et ingénieurs les
femmes de l'entreprise sont capables par
elle-même de faire la part des choses et
la médecine conventionnelle est loin de
répondre à toutes les questions qu'elles
se posent sur leur corps et leur santé
monsters king au visa de doctes nous
pouvons aller chez le médecin il
recevoir une ordonnance mais parfois on
sort de là et on se dit je n'ai pas eu
ce que je voulais sans prendre pour -
groupe offre une approche complémentaire
groupe projette cette diététicienne
vancouver qui est une grande fan de goût
crois que l entreprise séduit parce
qu'elle offre aux femmes un monde où
tout est beau tout est léché qui est
très différent de leur quotidien c'est
qui de mieux pour vendre le bien être
que gonnet facture c'est quand même une
très jolie femme est sortie et glee plus
beaux hommes sa planète elle choisit
d'être entrepreneur et ça fonctionne
parce qu'elle elle incarne l'essence
même de la marque et pour cette
spécialiste en marketing les femmes
souvent cherchent pas seulement de la
science mais aussi de lait coûte
nous on travaille beaucoup avec des gens
dans le monde médical puis quand on
regarde juste la relation que les gens
avec leur pharmacien
les pharmaciens qui considèrent les plus
compétents que ceux qui les écoutent le
plus donc ça rien à voir avec les
recommandations aux scientifiques
médicales que peut faire un pharmacien
oh alors les consommatrices canadienne
se laisseront séduire par l'entreprise
de gwyneth paltrow
ce sera aux femmes de s'informer et
décider